- We have to talk about this
because I love that you have Hotel Diablo.
This is really cool graphic novel.
- [Machine Gun] Thank you.
- By the way, like, literally
(crowd cheering)
This is like the new ...
this is the new way to
get kids into like reading
as well for like moms
- Totally.
- Because my kids love the graphic novels.
And that it's so funny because
we grew up with comic books,
but it's like different,
it's like next level.
- It's more cerebral,
It's more that, it's like,
it's almost like Twilight zone.
Like, you know what
inspired me a lot with this.
was the Tower of Terror ride
- I love that ride.
- When you go on it.
So it's interesting as like,
I don't know if the
algorithm is the right word,
but essentially every time you go on it,
it's a new version of that ride.
So even if you go on two seconds
after you just got off of it,
it takes you on a different.
- Yeah.
- It does something different every time.
- But it's the same building,
which I thought was really interesting.
And so this is it's five
stories with some interstitial
stories in it as well.
And they all like tackle
something that has to do with just like,
with social consciousness
or your own demons
or your own.
And it's cool because it's
not just like a guy in a cap,
which is a great...
- Message for kids, yeah.
Message but this one is like,
if you want to take that next
step into like, you know,
even like spirituality in a
sense, you know, like the.
- The best version of
yourself, are you getting that.
- Yeah and it's...
it's nice to have like really
beautiful images paired
with things that you can, you know,
'cause if your 10 year read
that and get something from it.
But when you're 30, you can read that
and get something much
different from it too, so.
- I love that.
- It's cool
(crowd applauding)
- And it's fun for like that,
I love that you just said that
because being a parent that reads,
I read every night my kids .
And it's awesome whenever
I'm as interested in them.
- Yeah.
- In what I'm reading,
you know, it's not like, well,
I'm interested in reading to my kids
but you know what I mean.
It's like watching those
movies (crowd laughing).
Like in your like Shrek's
funny (crowd laughing).
So you don't, you know what I'm saying?
You're like, I don't mind
watching it 15 times.
- Yeah.
- Yeah but this is so cool.
Have you always wanted to do this?
- I have, I like.
That was, I'm a really big reader.
I'll never forget when I
read 20,000 Leagues onto the,
Under the Sea.
- Wow.
- And I was so fascinated
by a fantasy world.
- Me too.
- And then I graduated into,
you know, that's a long book.
So it was nice to like read
something that you could read.
- I love Escapism like that.
- Me too.
- That's why that's...
Yeah, I love fiction because
it's nice to like get
- Book Club.
- Yeah, Book Club.
(crowd laughing)
(crowd applauding)
- Machine Gun and Kelly (laughing).
To great Book Club